[Music]
moving to the cloud can be a game
changer for today's enterprise
businesses
but to truly take advantage of the
benefits that the cloud can offer
leaders need to be equipped with an
understanding of how to formulate
and implement an effective cloud
strategy gain the knowledge you need to
lead that transformation with udacity's
cloud computing for business leaders
executive program
today every company needs to be a
technology company
i work closely with cios and ctos as
their trusted advisor to make the move
to the cloud
i designed this course so that every
company can stay relevant
and comparative in this cloud world
through this course
you will be able to identify the vast
business opportunity that cloud
technology unlocks
and understand the core cloud computing
concepts and practices that will help
you make the tough
it driven decisions required to
implement an effective cloud strategy
along the way you'll learn how to craft
a strong business case
and cost estimate for cloud migration
implement a governance model
and lead change management within your
organization
the global cloud computing market is
growing exponentially as more and more
companies are making rapid and permanent
moves to the cloud
regardless of where you are in your
company's cloud adoption journey
the cloud computing for business leaders
executive program will help you take
advantage of the massive opportunity
that the cloud holds for your business
be at the forefront of your business's
digital transformation
enroll today in udacity's cloud
computing for business leaders executive
program